the latest system software update is
here so get ready for a streamlined
interface and more ways to personalize
and share your experience let's dive
right into it the ps4 main interface has
been refreshed with a new look and
improved notifications what's new has an
updated layout and you can now interact
with posts much quicker personalize your
interface with brand new system
backgrounds
organize your content using folders in
the content launcher and library
it's easy to edit folders sort and
delete content live detail now give you
even more content related to your games
[Music]
get to the games you want in an instant
with a new sorting options in your
library the purchase content tab in your
library will show you all of your own
content including your beaters and demos
the alt tab will show content you
currently have installed and the new
search function gives you quicker access
to what you want
press and hold the PS button to reveal
the new look quick menu make the ps4
experience your very own by customizing
your menu so that you have access to
your most used features without leaving
your game sharing has never been easier
with the updated share menu during
gameplay
simply press the share button on your
controller to start a live broadcast
or share videos to your social media
with Twitter videos now increase to one
hundred and forty seconds
share screenshots directly to a
community wall and reply to an existing
post to make sure you're always a part
of the conversation new features will
help you find new friends and compare
profiles and don't forget to stand out
with the new user profile customization
these are just a few of the brand new
features in the new system software
update 4.0 for the players